hey I'm Ryan dawn of the Planet of the  Apes is out and a YouTube user named  Jake Styles has commanded me to watch  this trailer and I guess I'm excited  about it I really like Rise of the  Planet of the Apes I just want this  movie to be more realistic you know like  if if these guys were Apes like real  Apes maybe [ __ ] the whole time 20th  Century Fox The Walking Dead I spent  four years this feels like The Dark  Knight Rises Commissioner Gordon versus  the walking dead Oh dig in the music I  need just fake to say czar  hell yeah I forgot how much I like  rising it's not just about sit on giving  yourself to rebuild every claim the one  that we lost  dan the effects look so good so these  are real napes  it's kind of scary like really scary I  really puts you in the mindset that like  Apes could really take over if they  wanted to there's a lot of [ __ ] Apes